John, tu peux le faire, tu y vas et tu
ne regardes pas en arrière toute ma vie J'ai préparé
mon fils à diriger l'humanité dans la lutte
contre les machines nous reprenons notre
monde il y avait une chose que je ne pourrais jamais le
préparer pour le toboggan de la machine à  truquer
le jeu a renvoyé un terminateur à l'
époque d'avant la guerre pour tuer ma mère
je vais y retourner laissez-moi la sauver
je vais Reese vous savez pourquoi nous
vous préparons à arriver depuis plus d'une
décennie nous le terminateur  C'est un plaisir de
vous rencontrer J'ai essayé de lui apprendre
à se fondre Je sais qu'il a besoin de travail John
uh-huh comment pouvez-vous être ici
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait à la survie de mon fils c'est
ce que vous m'avez appris
sortir
pas machine pas homme
amor
je  je ne peux pas le laisser quoi qu'ils aient fait à
John nous avons besoin d'une répétition
tout a changé nous sommes le
dernier espoir de l'humanité charger